do you still believe there were 81
million votes
for the man who reads end of quote
[Laughter]
during a speech on tuesday the king of
naps learned there's some stuff in the
prompter you're not supposed to read
like the instructions
you may have heard the ceo of walmart
yesterday
on the steps we've taken he said and i
quote
the combination of private enterprise
and government working together has been
really successful
because of the actions we've taken
things have begun to change
and to quote
[Laughter]
it happens to the best of us
like the time i thought the teleprompter
was telling me to kill cat timf
yeah laugh you think she's off for
thanksgiving
but biden was spared embarrassment by
the fact he didn't seem to realize it
even he doesn't listen to himself
anymore but at least bine's still on
good terms with vice president harris
it's nice he has a friend along who's
also unpopular
they appeared together at a dc soup
kitchen which is doing great business
during his presidency
paris showed a real fondness for each
other and he definitely didn't appear to
ignore her the whole time
i kid they seem about as close as
siberia and texas
or maybe he was distracted by all the
soup it's the chewiest food dr jill lets
him have
finally after touting the release of 50
million barrels of oil from our
strategic reserves some of it diverted
to moisturize nancy pelosi's face
joe
joe says we should rest easy
all these concerns a few weeks ago
there would be uh there'd not be ample
food available for thanksgiving so many
people talked about that
understandably but families can rest
easy grocery stores are well stocked
with turkey and everything you know so
you need for thanksgiving
and the major retailers i mentioned are
can have confirmed
that their shelves will be well stocked
in stores this holiday season
hey so rest easy everything's fine
according to the guy who's in bed by 6
p.m
enjoy that turkey if you can get it it's
only 24 more expensive this year right
joe
look look look
everybody is gonna take it easy all
right
take it easy
take it
easy
don't let the sound of your own wheels
it's thanksgiving
all right
so just you know when you have your
turkey have some turkey and you sit in
your
easy chair
and you just think about
nothing no problems
nothing on your mind
why did i run for president
i don't know
a pumpkin pie
that was great tom um
do you like before you do these videos
do you try to stay up as late along as
possible so you're exhausted i did i had
a full meal so i was getting into
character yes so yes it is a concern of
mine i i do get tired we all get tired
after thanksgiving and to be honest i've
made that mistake with the teleprompter
when i was first here guess i think i
was guest hosting for you on the five
and they write direction but i didn't
know it was direction yes so i was like
and now let's go to the video stop
talking
why did i just say that yeah no i've
done it i've done it myself but then i
you know i i'm not in in politics for 50
years and leader of the world and he's
been doing teleprompters and you know so
he
has been practiced at this and he's
getting worse which tells you something
yeah degan if this is we're not even
through the first year i mean this is i
mean he's degrading rather quickly what
it's gonna be like in the next three is
he gonna be around uh he'll be around
but since kamala harris has clearly been
sidelined she's got no shot yeah she
they really aren't going to run her in
in three years so go for broke like if
she if she's going to get the cole
shoulder work in the soup line she
should stand behind him at every
opportunity and just make just like hand
gestures like this
yes
or
to really scare
out of people start going boom boom like
mushroom
she's cloud nothing to lose no wonder
you know she did that though i don't
think dr jill would be happy with that
dr jill already doesn't like her what do
you think dr siegel do you think he's
got i hate asking medical experts
medical opinions because you haven't
examined the patient so maybe i
shouldn't ask but anyway do you think
he's going to make it
raise your hand if you think this man
needs an mri of the brain
raise your hand if you agree with
ambassador nikki haley who says all over
70 who are going to try to be a leader
need a cognitive test right yeah he's
49. i looked at the physical of biden
and they're saying he can't walk anymore
stiff-legged walk yeah that makes me
wonder what's going on upstairs but the
soup kitchen yeah
i i think it's
whether you have a problem thinking
clearly or not it's a disgrace to give
somebody a cold shoulder at a warm soup
kitchen ah there you go there you go
he's so happy with that one look at the
dog
by the way yours was the best you're
well you did amazing should win an emmy
i don't know that man thank you
jimmy last word to you what do you make
of this whole mess we call the
presidency well the whole soup kitchen
thing was hilarious but if you think
what biden did with the food was bad you
should see what hunter did with the
brownies not good
not
that way i would do that with the brown
yeah you would and that's why we love
you man yeah but uh no they uh people
think they hate each other i don't
actually think it's true joe and kamala
are actually opening a mexican chain
restaurant called not on the border yeah
and uh
it's a big hit no i mean we all know you
can read the body language they hate
each other there's no two ways about it
the fact that the white house you know
has gone out of its way to distance
themselves from her in the press that
doesn't happen by accident the press
doesn't report things this white house
doesn't want them to and you know he has
alienated kamala because he is privately
telling all of his friends that he's
running for president in 2012.
and
you know
she knows it's not good she's offended
yeah hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else